in the Bible God will often take
responsibility for something you do
because he allows you to do it for
example when Satan destroyed job didn't
God say you moved me against
job yeah but was it God who Moved
against job and struck him down or is it
Satan Satan okay but God said you made
me do it I and then didn't job say that
you know we ac we accept good and evil
from God but did the evil from God or it
came from Satan Satan okay who struck
down the firstborn of the Egyptians go
to Exodus
1212 before you go to 1 samel 66
yes Exodus 1212
1212 for I will pass through the land of
Egypt this night and I will Smite uh and
will Smite all the firstborn in the land
of Egypt both man and Beast and against
all the gods of Egypt I will execute
judgment I am the Lord who's going to
kill the
firstborn I God who's
I God okay but read Exodus
12:23 for the Lord will pass through to
Smite the Egyptians and when he seeth
the blood upon the lentil uh and the two
side posts the Lord will pass over the
door and will not suffer the Destroyer
to come in unto your houses to Smite you
wait who's now going to kill the
firstborn the Destroyer but God said I
will yeah because God will take
responsibility for the actions of
another when God allows that person to
act on his desires but it's not God
doing it so now who hardened Pharaoh's
heart God or Pharaoh well go to 1st
Samuel 66
1 Samuel
66 wherefore then do ye Harden your
hearts as the Egyptians and Pharaoh
hardened their hearts when he had
wrought wonderfully among them did they
not let the people go and they departed
wait wait read that again uh that was
music to my ears yeah mine too wherefore
then do ye Harden your hearts as the
Egyptians and Pharaoh hardened their
hearts oh so pharaoh and the Egyptians
hardened their own Hearts yeah yeah but
I thought God hardened their
hearts yeah this is uh new to me and
when did they Harden their hearts notice
when they did finish it as the Egyptians
and Pharaoh Harden their hearts when he
had wrought wonderfully among them did
they not let the people go and they
departed so as God was doing Miracles
they Harden their hearts
more
yeah so who really hardened whose heart
well this verse says they hardened their
own Hearts okay so then what is it mean
when it says God Harden his
heart he let them Harden their own
Hearts yes God instead
of drawing them he now hands them over
to the desires of their heart and that's
how God hardens you when God is fed up
with you he then hands you over to your
desires and allows you to be enslaved by
your desires
are you seeing
it yes this is a lot to take in but I
appreciate because you're not seeing it
so I'm gonna ask you again who destroyed
the firstborn was it God or the
Destroyer the Destroyer but God said I
will yes who destroy job and his family
God or Satan Satan but God said you move
me to destroy job so you're still not
getting it in second Samuel 241 read it
for
Me 2 Samuel 24:1
24 and again the anger of the Lord was
kindled against Israel and he moved
David against them to say wait who Moved
David who Moved caused David to sin
against God by numbering
Israel and he moved read it who is it
beginning of the verse brother it's
right in front of you the beginning of
the verse yeah the Lord so Jehovah God
moved caused David to sin against God by
numbering
Israel well it seems like it from the
verse what seems like it it's black and
white dude don't make me R I'm gonna
hang myself in my Sho strings brother
sorry yeah yeah well yeah it says the
Lord so who Moved David caused David to
number Israel and sin against
God the Lord okay Jehovah right yeah but
in 1 Chronicles 211 it says Satan did it
go to 1 Chronicles
211 there it says Satan did it so who
did it Man 1 Chronicles 211 and Satan
stood stood up against Israel and
provoked David to number okay was it
Satan or God man Satan but no 2 Sam 24
said it was God
yeah so did Satan destroy job or God
destroyed
job Satan no but it says God did God
told Satan you moved me against him well
would it be right to say hold on did God
destroy the firstborn or the Destroyer
destroyed the
firstborn the Destroyer but God said I
will so did God Harden Pharaoh's heart
or Pharaoh Harden his
heart would it be fair to say that God
let that's what I've been telling you
man y when it says God did something
he's not the act of cause of it he is
permitting it so he's passive and that
okay that's what you want I'll give you
what you want I'll hand you over so God
allowed Satan to destroy job that's why
God says I did it God allowed Satan to
tempt David to number Israel and that's
why God God says I did it God allowed
the Destroyer to kill the first born but
stopped them from killing the firstborn
of the Israelites so in allowing it God
says he did it yes God hands pharaoh and
the Egyptians over to their unbelief and
in handing them over he then says he
hardened their
hearts yes so what's there not to get
God did not actively Harden Pharaoh's
heart he played what they call a passive
role in handing pharaoh and the
Egyptians over to what they already
wanted and desired rejection of God and
the worship there were gods and
goddesses yes so why did God then hand
pharaoh and the Egyptians over to their
unbelief and quote unquote in that sense
Harden their hearts because with every
opportunity when Pharaoh rejects God
that allowed God to do another miracle
before their eyes and ears that they
could not refute to give them
irrefutable proof he is God and they
have no excuse to reject them and now
that they reject him they suffer the
consequences yes so where is Calvinism
here there is no
Calvinism yeah I I agree okay now the
juicy part do you know when Pharaoh
hardened his heart against
God uh no every time God showed him
Mercy did you know
that no if you read Exodus again I want
you to it
every time God brought a plague Pharaoh
told Moses pray to God and I'll let your
people go every time God withheld the
plague Pharaoh became more
hardened okay so Exodus 10 what Exodus
the entire section that's it I'm
throwing myself out the damn window
every plague that God brought down what
did Pharaoh ask Moses to do tell God to
refrain to pull back this plague of
frogs or lies and let you go and when
God did that when he took back the
plague Pharaoh became more hardened yeah
right yeah that's right so when did
Pharaoh become more
hardened when God showed mercy so you
see it was the mercy of God that Harden
Pharaoh showing how evil he is that in
light of God's mercy he became more
embolden against God instead of humbling
himself yes so did he then get what he
deserves yeah if I show you mercy and
this is how you
respond then that means you are now have
reached the point of no return you're so
corrupt and hardened that even in light
of my Mercy you become more embolden to
defy
me yeah so you're good for nothing but
destruction that's why Romans N9 says he
is a vessel of Destruction because he
made himself such and how because every
time God showed him compassion all right
I'm gonna refrain from the plague all
right I will
withhold my judgment Pharaoh says to you
know what I'm going to make it even more
hell for you
Moses Miracle after Miracle plague after
plague when God then shows him mercy and
compassion Pharaoh becomes more embolden
more stiff neck showing yet had reached
the point of reprobation there was no
return for him yeah there you go